sacs de riz d'un coup pour cette année
c'est 13 1750 l'année dernière c'était
12500 donc les prix augmentaient sur le
marché
pas mal
à
mais vous verrez plus faire
la grimace non mais vous commencez
l'univers y a des couilles à sow blessé
d'un coup de
crosse d'armé san
francisco a publié début mars un moyen
de subvenir nbc
carol ward et ramassez pas fait comme
l'affairé d'ailleurs comme le revoilà
les
young
boys de berne
à voir avant la ramaz et à beaucoup de
familles qui m'ont contacté mais même
certaines et m'a appelé au téléphone en
pleurs
la situation est grave et dangereuse
parce que même les aliments habituels 33
consommation traditionnelle on va dire
au sénégal pour la plupart sont importés
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
dépendons clairement de la logistique
extérieur nous dépendons très rarement
aussi de la hausse des prix extérieur
s'est par exemple des le bétail qui
venait du mali avec le la crise qui
sévit au mali avec des sanctions de la
cedeao ça explique clairement la hausse
du prix de la viande au niveau des
marchés parce que totalement le bétail
ne passe plus les frontières